Seguro seguro que todos recordáis estas
trágicas imágenes que tuvieron lugar
hace más de una década
el accidente en la central nuclear de
fukushima daichi que se produjo a raíz
del Gran terremoto de tojo un movimiento
sísmico de magnitud 9 trajo consigo los
peores recuerdos del Terrible accidente
de Chernobyl al final por fortuna la
gravedad de este accidente no fue ni
mucho menos de la misma dimensión que el
de la central de pripiat Sin embargo
pese a ello provocó una enorme campaña
antinuclear a lo largo y ancho de todo
el mundo y entonces la carrera de muchos
países por deshacerse de este tipo de
energía fue más rápida que usain bolt
corriendo unos 100 metros ahora bien ya
ha pasado más de una década y ahora lo
que nos encontramos es con una enorme
crisis energética en todo el mundo
[Música]
en el caso de Japón tras el accidente de
fukushima se llegaron a cerrar los 50
reactores nucleares que tenía el país y
desde entonces 21 se dieron de baja y
solo 10 están en activo el resto siguen
detenidos a la espera de que se
Determine Su futuro las energías
renovables pero también la producida con
carbón y sobre todo con gas natural
licuado han sustituido a la energía
producida por este enorme parque nuclear
con el que contaba Japón
en este gráfico podéis ver por ejemplo
Cómo ha cambiado el mix energético del
país nipón desde el fatídico accidente
del 2011 como veis la moratoria nuclear
supuso que se disparara el consumo de
Carbón y gas natural para producir
electricidad Así que si te preocupan las
emisiones de CO2 en este momento estarás
tirándote de los pelos
El caso es que ahora la falta de
inversión en el sector Durante los
últimos años y las consecuencias de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania han hecho que
los precios del gas se disparen de tal
forma que si fueran japonés Que estarías
tirando de los pelos pero sobre todo por
la factura Pues bien Esto es exactamente
lo que explica que ahora más de una
década después de fukushima nos lleguen
noticias como esta Japón regresa a la
energía nuclear en un cambio post
fukushima este reinicio de las plantas
de energía nuclear japonesas Sería bueno
para liberar cantidades importantes de
lng para el mercado global que eso quizá
de amor y director de la oficina de
seguridad y mercados energéticos de la
asociación Internacional de la energía
como resultado de la invasión rusa de
Ucrania la situación energética global
ha cambiado drásticamente fue mi
oxicidad Primer Ministro de Japón os lo
hemos contado ya en el boletín semanal
que recibís todos los que nos apoyáis en
patreon Por cierto si os gusta lo que
hacemos y queréis apoyar que este
proyecto siga creciendo al tiempo que
beneficios como este boletín echadle un
vistazo a nuestro patreon os dejo el
enlace en la descripción y mil gracias a
todos los que ya formáis parte de
patreon
Pero bueno El caso es que Japón ha
decidido regresar por la puerta grande a
la industria nuclear ahora la pregunta
es cómo es posible que sea precisamente
el país en el que se originó la última
mayor fiebre antinuclear del planeta el
que ahora vaya a abandonar el
resurgimiento de esta misma energía cómo
piensa exactamente Japón impulsar una
nueva era nuclear Y todavía más
importante Hasta qué punto la decisión
de Japón marca un punto de inflexión en
el sector energético mundial Pues bien
todo esto y mucho más es lo que vamos a
contar a continuación así que sin más
dilación empecemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no es ningún secreto ni tampoco ninguna
novedad hace años los países más ricos
trazaron un plan para descarbonizarse un
plan que necesariamente pasa por una
estrategia concreta la electrificación
masiva de nuestra forma de vida ahí
tenemos sin ir más lejos la moda del
coche eléctrico de esta forma si tenemos
en cuenta tanto el crecimiento económico
esperado como este proceso de
electrificación masiva el resultado es
que las estimaciones de la agencia
Internacional de la energía apuntan a
que la demanda global de Electricidad se
va a disparar concretamente se espera
que pase atentos desde los 23.000
teravatios hora en 2020 a más de 60.000
en 2050 es decir que todo apunta a que
la demanda de Electricidad prácticamente
se va a multiplicar por 3 Durante los
próximos 28 años es decir que para
responder a esta enorme demanda
tendríamos que multiplicar prácticamente
por tres todas las infraestructuras de
producción eléctrica del mundo
digitales de gas de petróleo las
hidroeléctricas las renovables pues
imagináis lo que todo esto va a suponer
no se trata ya de sustituir los
combustibles fósiles por energías más
limpias sino de triplicar al mismo
tiempo la producción y eso eso queridos
amigos son palabras mayores
para que os hagáis una idea en 2021 la
producción eléctrica con combustibles
fósiles es decir carbón gas y petróleo
representó el 60% del total a nivel
mundial para los que estéis preocupados
por las emisiones apuntad que esta
producción supuso emitir 13,8 giga
toneladas de CO2
es decir Durante los próximos 28 años
Tendremos que triplicar la capacidad
mundial de producción eléctrica y si al
mismo tiempo queremos reducir las
emisiones Entonces tenemos un serio
problema Por qué Pues porque
difícilmente las energías renovables van
a poder cubrir por sí mismas semejante
demanda de energía eléctrica entre otras
cosas porque hablamos de fuentes que no
son constantes por lo que siempre
necesitan una fuente de energía fósil de
respaldo Así que no solo se trataría de
inundar el mundo con paneles solares y
Molinos de viento sino también
concentrales de gas natural Hablamos de
una inversión gigantesca que cada vez
más voces consideran completamente
inviable incluso las voces de quienes
quizás menos te lo esperas ahora Los
verdes de Finlandia apoyan totalmente la
energía nuclear y otro caso es
precisamente el de Japón pero hasta
dónde llega esta apuesta sabías que la
energía nuclear puede tener otros usos
adicionales a la generación eléctrica
puede la energía nuclear ser clave para
fabricar nuevos combustibles
de sustituir a la gasolina al diésel o
al queroseno en coches camiones barcos y
aviones pues atentos
[Música]
nucleares sí Arigato
bien como os decíamos Japón es uno de
los países que han anunciado que
recobrarán su Apuesta por la energía
nuclear Aunque lo cierto Es que no es el
único Polonia reforma las leyes para
acelerar las inversiones En energía
nuclear en septiembre del año pasado se
anunció que podrían construirse para
2040 seis grandes reactores de agua
presurizada con una capacidad conjunta
instalada de entre 6 y 9 gigavatios
eléctricos como parte del plan de
Polonia para reducir su historia alta
dependencia del Carbón Corea del Sur
elevará la energía nuclear a un tercio
del suministro energético el objetivo
supera las directrices del comité de
desarrollo nuclear de la ocde Francia
construirá hasta 14 nuevos reactores
nucleares para 2050 dice macron ya lo
veis la energía nuclear está resurgiendo
con fuerza tan solo china es para
invertir unos 400.000 millones de
dólares Durante los próximos 15-20 años
para construir agarrados a la Silla
150 nuevos reactores nucleares
[Música]
así que ya veis que no se trata solo de
Japón Aunque eso sí lo que sí hace de
este país un caso especial es que fue
uno de los países más antinucleares de
la última década y al mismo tiempo
también uno de los que más en serio se
habían tomado la investigación nuclear
antes de fukushima Claro está gracias a
esta situación ahora uno de los grandes
protagonistas del plan nipón es el
conocido como reactor de prueba de
ingeniería de alta temperatura el httpr
de Japón quiere que sea el tipo de
reactor que marque el futuro de la
energía nuclear en el país a largo plazo
hablamos de un reactor modular pequeño
de los conocidos Como smr y lo cierto Es
que la cosa Va muy en serio de hecho
este reactor que está instalado en la
prefectura de ivar aquí lleva en pruebas
más de dos décadas y ahora ahora aparece
que ha llegado su momento y ojo Porque
la idea con la que se trabaja es que sus
funciones no se queden solo en la
generación de electricidad fijaos
[Música]
la principal peculiaridad de este
reactor refrigerado con helio es que no
necesita agua lo cual hace que pueda
situarse prácticamente en cualquier
lugar del planeta y además por su propio
diseño y núcleo no puede entrar en
fusión a priori Es toda una Revolución
además y esto es muy importante puede
funcionar a temperaturas muy elevadas de
más de 900 grados y de esta forma entre
toda esa cantidad de calor y la
electricidad que genera es capaz de
producir grandes cantidades de hidrógeno
[Música]
Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien hidrógeno
aquí en visualpolitik ya os hablamos de
este elemento químico en un pasado vídeo
donde os contamos que existían tres
grandes tipos de hidrógeno el gris el
azul y el verde Pues bien Lo cierto es
que hay otro más un cuarto tipo de
hidrógeno el rosa que es precisamente el
producido con energía nuclear y como
también nos contamos Japón es uno de los
países que más en serio se están tomando
el tema del hidrógeno y como veis ahora
su nuevo programa nuclear tiene mucho
que ver con ello Y es que si hablamos de
hidrógeno y de Japón no hablamos de una
idea o un futurible sino de un hecho
fijaos
[Música]
el plan estratégico de energía de Japón
ha aprobado en octubre del 2021
Establece que se utilizarán precisamente
este tipo de reactores nucleares de gas
de alta temperatura para producir
hidrógeno además la estrategia de
crecimiento verde para conseguir la
neutralidad de carbono en 2050 de junio
de 2021 dice que será necesario la
reactores httpr para producir hidrógeno
libre de emisiones en grandes cantidades
y bajo coste para el año 2030
[Música]
lo que en términos de infraestructuras
estratégicas quiere decir a la vuelta de
la esquina y ojo porque esto no es algo
que simplemente se les haya ocurrido a
Los japoneses y ya está la propia
agencia Internacional de la energía lo
considera un objetivo clave para poder
cumplir con los planes de
descarbonización para el año 2050
[Música]
así que ya lo veis esta nueva aplicación
de producir además de Electricidad
también enormes cantidades de hidrógeno
libre de emisiones le pueden dar a la
energía nuclear un nuevo rol que hasta
ahora no tenía lo que significa otro
impulso más para esta industria y no
precisamente uno pequeño ahora bien ya
vamos a este punto puede que muchos os
estéis preguntando pero a ver Alberto
porque es tan importante el hidrógeno a
ver Pues básicamente porque cada vez más
expertos lo ven como un combustible
capaz de sustituir el uso de gasolina
diésel o queroseno en la industria en el
transporte Pesado en el tráfico marítimo
e incluso en los aviones un combustible
potencialmente limpio e ilimitado que
además puede incluso llegar a ser
utilizado como batería o sistema de
almacenamiento eléctrico
de esta forma según la propia agencia
Internacional de la energía si en 2020
se produjeron unas 90 millones de
toneladas de hidrógeno para el año 2050
se espera que la producción alcance como
mínimo los 500 millones de toneladas El
problema es que actualmente apenas el
10% de la producción de hidrógeno se
realiza de forma limpia con lo cual si
se quieren cumplir los objetivos de
misiones hará falta muchísima energía
barata y libre de misiones para poder
cumplir una demanda de energía que no
dejará de crecer y justo Aquí es donde
entran en juego los pequeños reactores
modulares que podrían instalarse cerca
de los centros industriales y de las
ciudades
De todas formas si queréis saber más
sobre el hidrógeno os dejamos en la
descripción el vídeo que ya publicamos
aquí en visualpolitik Pero esto no es
todo
[Aplausos]
Además del hidrógeno la energía nuclear
sería Útil para producir otros
combustibles sintéticos incluso Japón
también está investigando como canalizar
el calor producido en estos reactores
para poder aprovecharlo en los sistemas
de calefacción urbana de esta forma
estos reactores podrían cumplir tres
objetivos producir electricidad producir
hidrógeno y combustibles sintéticos y
abastecer los sistemas de calefacción y
todo ello sin un solo gramo de CO2
emitido a la atmósfera nos parece
increíble seguro que ahora entenderéis
mejor por qué tantos países están
sumando a esta nueva corriente ahora
bien stop un momento seguro que a muchos
de vosotros tenéis una objeción pero
vamos a ver Alberto todo esto que nos
estás contando que sí que está muy bien
que es muy bonito pero construir una
central nuclear lleva un montón de años
y resulta muy caro carísimo es imposible
que todo esto sea factible de aquí al
año 2050 Pues a ver en cierto modo nos
falta razón aunque con muchos matices
atentos
realidades distintas
un vistazo a este gráfico lo que estáis
viendo en pantalla es el tiempo mínimo
medio y máximo que ha tardado cada país
con energía nuclear en construir sus
centrales como veis países como
Argentina o Estados Unidos tienen
centrales que tardaron más de 20 años en
construirse por diferentes motivos en
cualquier caso una locura sin embargo
podemos fijarnos también en la otra
parte del gráfico en el extremo
contrario
[Música]
Japón es el país que más rápido
construye centrales nucleares durante
unos 40 años sus centrales han tenido un
plazo medio de construcción de entre 3 y
5 años otros países como Corea del Sur
también manejan tiempos muy razonables
con una media de unos 6 años
La pregunta es por qué existen tantas
diferencias en cuanto a los tiempos de
producción Pues bien aquí nos tapamos
con los grandes dilemas o dificultades
que tiene esta tecnología sobre todo en
occidente primero la industria nuclear
occidental y sobre todo la europea está
por lo general hecha trizas tras años de
fuertes desinversiones hablamos de falta
de innovación pero sobre todo de
problemas en la cadena de suministro y
proveedores lo que resulta lógico sino
construyes centrales no esperes tener
proveedores listos para ayudarte luego
Tenemos también la cuestión regulatoria
y las trabas burocráticas incluso En
aquellos países que permiten la energía
nuclear el plazo para conseguir
licencias estudios ambientales estudios
de riesgo o simplemente escoger una
localización factible es enorme durante
las últimas décadas la energía nuclear
no ha sido popular y eso se nota por
supuesto cuanto mayor es el plazo de
selección diseño regularización y
construcción mayores son también los
costes estas son cuestiones a re
[Música]
pero amigos amigas sea como sea si algo
parece claro es que la energía nuclear
está de vuelta incluso Japón ha dado
marcha atrás a su moratoria nuclear y
ahora quiere apostar de lleno por esta
tecnología china Corea del Sur emiratos
árabes Unidos el Reino Unido Finlandia
Polonia y otros muchos países están en
la misma dirección todo apuntar a que
estamos solo ante el comienzo de una
Nueva Ola la energía nuclear puede
suministrar electricidad abundante y
barata y ahora también hidrógeno e
incluso calor y eso en los tiempos que
corren es mucho decir pero llegamos
hasta aquí turno para ti os gustaría que
vuestros países apostaran más por la
energía nuclear Qué te parece la idea de
tener pequeños reactores modulares muy
seguros construidos cerca de las
ciudades y los principales centros
industriales déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante No olvides darle a
like y suscribirte aquí al politik si es
que aún no lo has hecho muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]